Welcome to the assignments for lesson two. Now the assignments for
this lesson are probably the most involved and time consuming of
the entire class. They may take you three to four hours
to complete if you do them thoroughly. So, if you do
find yourself getting drained or bored or just running out of
time, don't rush through them. You should do these well if
you're going to do them at all. But, you should feel
free to either skip ahead to lesson three, or if you're
getting bored, just take a break. If you do decide
to take a break, I would definitely, set a calendar
invite for yourself to remind you to come back for
the class. It's pretty easy to forget that. Good luck